ليله امس تاهل المنتخب الفرنسي للنهائي
كاس العالم بعد فوزه على منتخب المغرب
بهدفين مقابل الشيء منتخب المغرب اللي من
اول البطوله بقدم مستوى مبهر امس ما كان
اقل الابهر لكن هذه هي الرياضه يعني للاسف
فيها فايز وخسران ومن وقت ما خلصت
المباراه والتحيات والتهاني لمنتخب المغرب
على الظهور والاداء المشرف ملينا من الصوت
والعناوين خاصه طبعا مع الانجاز التاريخي
لحققه لكن بعيدا كمان عن المنتخب ككل في
تفصيله ثانيه متعلقه بالمباراه وشغله من
الصوت ومتداول بشكل كبير كمان والتفسير
بتخص لاعب فرنسا كيليان مبابي وش لاعب
المغرب اشرف حكيمي كمان اللاعبين اللي كل
واحد منهم يعني من اهم نجوم منتخب بلده
لكن همم يعني ممكن يقول ان هم الاهم صراحه
يعني كمان لكنهم كانوا خصمان همم مع انهم
في الحقيقه هم زميلين في نادي باريس سان
جيرمان صداقه وعلاقه قويه جدا في الواقع
ومن وقت ما تاهلوا عرفوا انهم هم راحوا
يواجهوا بعض كانت التعليقات على هذا
الموضوع شغاله وحتى راح اشرف مزح كيلين
على تويتر وقال له نلتقي قريبا ورد عليه
صديقه اما بعد المباراه فكلين وصل صديق
وعلى تويتر كمان وكتب له مع صوره لهم لا
تحزن يا صديقي الجميع فخور بما حققت لقد
دخلت التاريخ وحكيم يرد عليه باموجيز قلب
حب وسلام بالايدين همم خلونا المشاهدين ان
نتفاهم مع صور متداوله بشكل واسع من
المباراه امس مبابي وحكيم الصديقين اللي
90 دقيقه بس امس كانوا
[موسيقى]